[Applaus]
[Musik]
der kalte krieg ist schon vor langer
zeit zu ende gegangene zumindest wollen
sie uns das glauben machen im alten
europa gibt es eine region in der der
schatten moskaus noch sehr präsent ist
so sehr dass man fast sagen könnte dass
der kalte krieg in gewisser weise drei
jahrzehnte nach dem ende der sowjetunion
noch immer quicklebendig ist deswegen
werden wir dieser region heute unsere
aufmerksamkeit schenken ich bald im
norden und eingekeilt zwischen
mitteleuropa und skandinavien auf der
freundlichen seite und russland und
weißrussland auf der feindlichen seite
liegen die drei baltischen staaten
estland lettland und litauen
[Musik]
die drei baltischen staaten wagen bis
zum zusammenbruch der sowjetunion im
jahr 1991 teil des kommunistischen
riesenreichs das heißt estland lettland
und litauen waren keine was allen
staaten wie polen oder ungarn sondern
teil der kommunistischen großmacht
selbst die frage die uns vor allem
beschäftigt ist jedoch der grund warum
das baltikum schon immer ein
schlüsselthema für moskau war und immer
noch ist ihr privilegierter zugang zur
ostsee einem mehr dass sie direkt mit
dem motor europas verbindet deutschland
außerdem haben sich die drei republiken
zu einer der wohlhabendsten regionen in
europa entwickelt
tatsache ist dass viele militärexperten
diese region aus diesen und auch anderen
gründen als potenzielles pulverfass
betrachten ein zentrum tiefer
politischer und militärischer spannungen
vor allem militärische
litauen sagt zwei russische militärs
hätten seinen luftraum verletzt 86
entdecken russisches militär flugzeug
der lettischen grenze
estlands akt russische flugzeug der
verletzten erneut seinen luftraum wie du
siehst breiten die baltischen staaten
der nato ziemliches kopfzerbrechen
obwohl sie nur ein relativ kleiner
streifen von 100 75 quadratkilometern
sind das entspricht der größe eines
landes wie uruguay um den russischen
bedrohung entgegenzuwirken gilt ist die
grenzen zu schützen und den einfluss
moskaus zu begrenzen
[Musik]
die frage ist wie hoch die nato dies zu
erreichen warum sie diese drei jungen
demokratien ins zentrum des interesses
der westlichen institutionen gerückt was
sind ihre wichtigsten stärken und
schwächen und vielleicht die wichtigste
frage von allen könnte die nato eine
russische invasion nach vorbild der
astro metrischen übersetzung der ukraine
abwehr keine angst in diesem video
werden wir diese und noch viele andere
interessante fragen zu dieser
geopolitischen schlüsselregion
beantworten zuerst müssen sie aber noch
schnell ein wenig geld verdienen unser
heutiger sponsor ist cirque vbl ein
wirklich sicheres vpn dass wir getestet
haben dass weder datenverkehr noch meter
unter verbindungsdaten mit lockt und
außerdem jede menge security tools
mitbringt so stark ist aber auch aus
vielen anderen gründen ein ganz tolles
vpn natürlich könnt ihr mit dessen hilfe
auf websites und internet dienste
zugreifen die in dem land in dem wir
gerade seid nicht verfügbar sind ohne
zensur und georg login ob daheim oder im
urlaub darüber hinaus bietet es jedoch
weitere sicherheits-features habt ihr
nicht zum beispiel auch ein mulmiges
gefühl durch die allgegenwärtigen wärme
popups und cookies bis zuschlag bekommt
ihr ein freundliches tun haben wird dass
sie alle bloggt und die damit
verbundenen gefahren beseitigt aber
nicht nur das mit nur einem surfer konto
könnt ihr alle eure geräte im vpn
registrieren handys notebooks und sogar
eure smart tvs deckt wirklich alle arten
von geräten ab ihr bekommt damit einen
lückenlosen schutz suchen weil wir euch
unsere treuen stack sowie haben waren
wir nun bereit dieses bonn sollen zu
übernehmen wenn euch surft auch einen
ordentlichen rabatt einräumt und das ist
uns gelungen mit hilfe des fahrradclubs
politik.de bekommt ihr sage und schreibe
83 prozent rabatt und obendrein die
ersten drei monate gratis dazu den link
zu diesem angebot findet ihr in der
beschreibung unter diesem video also
nichts wie los besorgt euch so stark und
hält damit gleichzeitig uns damit wir
auch weiterhin so schöne videos wie
dieses hier liefern können so und jetzt
ab ins baltikum
[Musik]
ein land zwei gesellschaften
denk mal einen moment darüber nach was
war wirklich der schlüsselfaktor der den
erfolg der russischen invasion in der
ukraine erklärt ok ich bin mir sicher
dass viele von euch an die gut
vorbereiteten und ausgerüsteten truppen
denken in russland vor ort stationiert
hat auch wenn sie nicht die russische
flagge tragen aber mal hand aufs herz
wäre der russische erfolg wirklich
möglich gewesen wenn es in der ukraine
keine großen gebiete mit rose strache
der bevölkerung gegeben hätte
[Musik]
und weißt du was was würdest du sagen
wenn ich dir verraten würde dass
dieselbe zutat auch hier an der grenze
zwischen den baltischen republiken und
mütterchen russland zu finden ist also
in litauen sind heute knapp fünf prozent
der bevölkerung müsse ständig und ja
diese zahl markt die nicht nur das hoch
erscheinen aber litauen ist tatsächlich
die ausnahme denn der anteil der
russischsprachigen bevölkerung in
estland liegt bei 24 prozent und
lettland sogar 25,2 prozent also rund
einem viertel natürlich stellt die
tatsache dass es an einem bestimmten ort
eine kleinere oder größere
russischsprachige bevölkerung gibt nicht
per se ein problem dar das problem
entsteht meist erst wenn ihre soziale
kulturelle und rechtliche integration
fehlschlägt und genau das ist hier
leider auch der fall schau dir zum
beispiel diesen ordner lasst mal mehr
dies mehrheitlich russisches viertel in
dem nur 104 einwohner nächste ist hier
ist die russische community unter sich
und dominant wir sprechen hier von mehr
als 80.000 einwohnern die starke
gemeinschaftliche bindungen
untereinander pflegen und in einem
echten freilichtmuseum der sowjet ära
leben es ist ein klein russland nur
innerhalb ist lanxess bildet den
wichtigsten russischen kern innerhalb
der hauptstadt tallinn in der mehr als
30 prozent der bevölkerung ethnische
russen sind wir sprechen hier von einer
bevölkerungsgruppe die und das ist
ausschlaggebend sehr ausgeprägte
eigenheiten hat zum beispiel sie die
einkommensschwächsten gebiete in den
drei baltischen republiken genau jene
mit den höchsten prozentsatz
russischstämmiger und sich vorsichtig
denn wir reden hier nicht von kleinen
einkommensunterschieden das
einkommensniveau kann um 40 bis 50
prozent niedriger sein als in den
einkommensstarken regionen aber das ist
noch nicht alles
[Musik]
die russische bevölkerung in den
baltischen staaten bildet eine
parallelgesellschaft werden diese
menschen beziehungsweise ihrer vorfahren
wurden dort 1840 gezielt von der
sowjetmacht angesiedelt um die weniger
realistisch bevölkerung zu verdünnen
estland war besetzt und sollte rossi
fixiert werden
viele dieser ethnischen russen vor allem
älterer sprechen noch nicht einmal ist
denn das waren die zeiten nicht nur
unnötig sondern auch unerwünscht und
auch 30 jahre nach dem fall des
kommunismus sind diese unterschiede
immer noch enorm so haben etwa die
hälfte der russischsprachigen einwohner
estlands ist heute doch keinen
estnischen passt etwa 70.000 davon sind
buchstäblich staatenlos nicht mal
russische staatsbürger ja das ist
richtig rund 70.000 menschen etwa sechs
prozent der gesamten auswirkungen des
landes haben keine staatsbürgerschaft
keinen pass und kein stimmrecht bei
wahlen
[Musik]
ohne lange suchen zu müssen können wir
hier in lassen ehe viele beispiele für
menschen finden die formell keinem land
angehören und ja ich weiß was du denkst
wie um alles in der welt kann so etwas
möglich sein anno 2020 in der eu
[Musik]
der ursprung dieser bezahlen situation
geht auf das jahr 1991 zurück als die
estnische regierung einen festen
beschluss fasste die staatsbürgerschaft
ausschließlich all jenen zu gewähren die
vor der sowjetischen besatzung 140
staatsbürger waren sowie deren
nachkommen für den rest für die russen
während der sowjetischen besatzung
gekommen waren gab es keine pässe und
nimm dich in acht denn etwas ganz
ähnliches ist auch in lettland passiert
einem land in dem sich etwa sieben
prozent der bevölkerung in der gleichen
situation befinden wir sprechen hier von
mehr als
130.000 staatenlosen menschen wie du dir
vorstellen kannst diese situation nicht
nur ausgrenzung ethnische trennung und
chancenlosigkeit für diese gruppe der
russischen bevölkerung sondern ist auch
der perfekte nährboden für die vom kreml
geförderten des informations und
manipulation strategie wisst ihr was in
moskau ist man sich dessen durchaus
bewusst genau aus diesem grund versucht
die russische regierung seit jahren in
dieser bevölkerungsgruppe ein gefühl der
konfrontation und nationalistischen
separation zu schüren wie weit ist der
kann also bisher gegangen und die
wichtigste frage von allen welches
potenzial haben soll sich strategien
wirklich aufgepasst
hybride kriegsführung
[Musik]
woher kommt das große interesse
russlands an den baltischen staaten ist
es eine frage von historischen
ressentiments geht es vielleicht darum
den einfluss der eu einzusetzen oder ist
eine frage des neo imperialismus nun die
antwort lautet alle diese gründe treffen
zu und auch keiner von ihnen und das
gleichzeitig denn auf dem papier besteht
das argument russlands aus der idee der
russischen welt und was genau ist diese
russischen welt meinem laden putin über
russland um das russische volk spricht
meint er nicht nur jene rosen die
innerhalb der heutigen russischen stars
ganzen leben sondern alle russen die auf
der ganzen welt verstreut sind und ganz
besonders in den ehemaligen sowjetischen
gebieten das ist sozusagen eine
erweiterte definition der politischen
verantwortung des kremls
[Musik]
das ganze ist vergleichbar mit adolf
hitlers visionen die vor dem zweiten
weltkrieg überall in europa verstreut
lebenden deutschen minderheiten heim ins
reich zu holen aber nicht indem sie ins
reich kommt sondern das reich zu ihnen
zusammen mit der wehrmacht irgendwie
scheint diese idee auch putin aber
halten mit russen stadt mit deutschen zu
imponieren deswegen wohl sein name auf
das ziel von verballhornungen ist die
eine referenz auf den deutschen diktator
darstellen die strategie punkt teams
besteht nun darin dieses konzept der
russischen welt zu verwirklichen in dem
so viele russischsprachigen minderheiten
wie möglich mit dem mutterland verbunden
werden denn er sieht diese russischen
minderheiten als ein zentrales
politisches instrument und den einfluss
des russischen imperiums zu vergrößern
das geht so war dass moskau schon in
vergangenen kriegen den schutz seiner
landsleute als hauptargument für sein
militärisches eingreifen anführte
wir sprechen zum beispiel über den krieg
in georgien oder die invasionen auf der
krim und im ukrainischen dorf aber jetzt
sprechen wir über das baltikum eu und
nato territorium um die frage die wir
uns stellen müssen ist was bedeutet das
alles wie beabsichtigt die russische
regierung ihren einfluß hier geltend zu
machen nun willkommen in der bunten welt
der hybriden kriegsführung übrigen die
kriegsführung ist eine art von nicht
konventionellen konflikt bei denen das
ziel darin besteht den feind zu
zermürben indem zum beispiel politische
wirtschaftliche und mediale mittel
kombiniert werden methoden die nicht
rein militärischer natur sind dies
geschieht zum beispiel durch des
informationskampagnen cyberangriffe
erpressung mit energie lieferstopps
einmischung in wahlen oder unterstützung
und ausbildung radikaler und
aufständischer gruppe all diese taktiken
haben einen enormen einfluss auf die
sicherheit eines landes und auch auf die
funktionsfähigkeit und sogar die
legitimität seine institutionen und ja
fast alle diese taktiken kommen gegen
das partie kaum zum einsatz bist du ein
paar konkrete beispiele dann wird mal
einen blick hierauf bericht russischer
hacker nutzen litauische infrastruktur
aus
mutmaßt nicht von russland unterstützte
hacker greifen die baltische
energienetze an und glaube nicht eine
sekunde lang das cyber angriffe die
einzigen beispiele sind die auf dem
tisch liegen wir können noch viele
weitere finden so finanziert die
russische regierung zum beispiel
heimlich eine gruppe von angeblich
unabhängigen nachrichtenwebsite namens
volt news die absicht ist es geschichten
und nachrichten zu verbreiten die direkt
vom kreml diktiert werden und das
narrativ verbreiten soll
[Musik]
alles mit dem ziel das baltikum von
seiner prowestlichen weltanschauung
abzubringen und von einer prorussischen
so überzeugen denn die russen sind sich
dessen bewusst was ist noch wichtiger
ist die breite masse der gesellschaft zu
beeinflussen als nur das politische
establishment aus diesem grund sind die
central ist vom internet informationen
kampagne fake news denunziation
datenerfassung sowie politische und
wirtschaftliche drohungen aber moment
mal denn das ist nicht die einzigen
mittel der übrigen tricks führung die
russland in dieser region europas
einsetzt aber es gibt noch eine weitere
noch besorgniserregender strategie die
strategie der ständigen anspannung
die russische militärpräsenz in dieser
region ist enorm wir reden hier von
einer solchen konzentration von waffen
und truppen dass viele militärexperten
bezweifeln dass die nato wirklich etwas
tun könnte um eine hypothetische
russische invasion zu stoppen aber
welchen charakter ist ist eigentlich
diese militärische bedrohung aus
russland der diese drei baltischen
länder estland lettland und litauen
ausgesetzt sein könnten schau doch mal
etwas genauer an
[Musik]
die achillesferse der nato
der ort denn gleich sehen wirst ist die
raketenbasis blog stine sie liegt im
westen litauens ganz in der nähe der
ostsee und sie war der erste
unterirdische atomwaffen schlusspunkt in
der gesamten sowjetunion
dies war einer jener orte die für die
zerstörerische kraft der roten armee von
zentraler bedeutung waren jahrelang war
sie einen brennpunkt in der
konfrontation zwischen ost und west und
heute er präsentiert wie kaum eine
andere den drei jungs des westlichen
blogs einst war sie ein wichtiger teil
des nuklearen abschreckung systems der
sowjetunion heute ist sie eine
öffentlich zugängliche anlage in einem
land das vollmitglied der nato ist ja
die nato im weltmacht system ein
wichtiges gegengewicht der demokratie
und freiheit gegen freiheitsbeschränkung
und expansionistische autokratien so
zumindest er selbst bild aber es ist
auch wahr dass diese organisation
schwächen hat empfindliche
schwachstellen und einige davon sind
genau in dieser region osteuropas zu
finden
in den drei baltischen staaten sind
derzeit nato stützpunkte und truppen
stationiert um die grenze zwischen dem
westlichen block und russland an land
zur see und in der luft zu verteidigen
heute sprechen von mehr als 35.000
soldaten wobei sowohl die nationalen
drucken dieser drei länder als auch die
verbände wie den usa großbritannien
deutschland und kanada in sandten
unterstützungseinheiten berücksichtigt
werden
[Musik]
aber natürlich sitzt russland in einem
hypothetischen konflikt im baltikum
nicht nur zahlenmäßig am längeren hebel
sondern auch in bezug auf mittel
fähigkeiten und geo strategie schauen
wir uns zum beispiel den fall liter uns
an der punkt den du gerade siehst ist
die so lucky luke einen streifen von
etwa 90 kilometer näher litauen mit
polen und im rest der nato länder in
europa verbindet das problem ist dass
alles was diesen korridor umgibt
feindliches gebiet ist weißrussland im
osten und das russische kaliningrad im
westen übrigens haben wir vor nicht
allzu langer zeit ein video über
kaliningrad gemacht weil ich das hier
hilft den allgemeinen kontext des kalten
kriegs im baltikum zu verstehen den link
dazu findest du in der beschreibung
unter diesem video ach und wenn wir
schon dabei sind hast du wieso alle
politik schon abonniert als nein dann
macht das jetzt damit du keines unserer
videos mehr verpasst aber lassen wir uns
nicht zu sehr vom thema ablenken die
frage ist wie leicht russland die drei
baltischen staaten isolieren kann wenn
es mal hart auf hart kommt
denn es würde ausreichen diese kleinen
dinge zu besetzen oder anzugreifen um
sie von nachschub und verstärkungen
abzuschneiden sie ist sozusagen ein
nadelöhr für nato-truppen und denkt
bitte daran dass wir hierbei nicht
unbedingt von einem offiziellen andere
sprechen militärexperten weisen auf die
mobilisierung einer nach außen regulären
truppen ähnlich denen die russland zur
besetzung der krim oder zur
destabilisierung des landes eingesetzt
hat tatsächlich ist eine solche
intervention vielleicht das worüber die
drei baltischen länder am meisten
besorgt sind nicht nur in diesem
korridor sondern vor allem in jenen
teilen ihrer jeweiligen gebiete die
mehrheitlich von russen bewohnt sind das
aber ist nicht der einzige
schwachpunkten achtung in der nähe von
kaliningrad hat das russische militär
ein supermodernes aktuell die militärs
system geschaffen aktuell die stete and
access arena es handelt sich um die
fähigkeit gegnerischen einheiten zu
lande zu wasser und in der luft
jeglichen zugang und bewegungsfreiheit
ausgewählten operationsgebiet mit
militärischen mitteln zu versagen und in
grund millimeter genau zu kontrollieren
wir sprechen von einem komplexen system
das es den russen ermöglicht die
bewegungen der nato-streitkräfte sowohl
in kaliningrad als auch in den
angrenzenden gebieten zu verhindern
erreicht wird dies durch ein netzwerk
von sich überlappenden
luftverteidigungssysteme darunter seit
2009 10 das russische flugabwehrsystem
s400 langstrecken artillerie
konventionelle und nukleare ballistische
raketen darunter zwölf iskander-raketen
systeme die sowohl konventionelle als
auch nuklear bestückt werden können und
marschflugkörper außerdem gibt es
schiffs und ab werder schon
elektronische kriegsführung systeme und
natürlich alles viel erfolg an
flugzeugen und plus 1 ein wahrlich
gewaltiges arsenal und nicht zu
vergessen die baltischen flotte welche
hier stationiert ist um zu verhindern
dass die nato ihre flotten in der region
gegen russland zum einsatz bringen
könnte auf diese weise versucht russland
nicht nur seine herrschaft über
kaliningrad aufrechtzuerhalten und
seinen einzigen ostseehafen zu schützen
wäre das ganze jahr über eisfrei ist
sondern auch die drei baltischen länder
und damit die nato als ganzes in schach
zu halten das problem bei dieser art von
eindrücken und rüsten ist das ein
kleiner fehler eine fehlinterpretation
oder ein dummes versehen zum falschen
zeitpunkt die dinge außer kontrolle
geraten lassen kann das ist das risiko
lettland warnt vor dem risiko eines
zwischenfalls zwischen der nato und
russland ihr habt eine krise an der
grenze er hat eine große militärübung an
den grenzen der nato-länder ihr habt
auch eine verstärkte präsenz von
grenzschützern und militärische
informationen auf unserer seite der
litauischen seite der technischen seite
der polnischen seite das erhöht
natürlich die wahrscheinlichkeit von
zwischenfällen chemisch außenministern
von lettland das argument russlands für
die aufrechterhaltung dieses riesigen
ausmaßes in der region ist natürlich
dass es aus seiner sicht die nato ist
welche die region umzingelt hat für die
nato ist kaliningrad jedoch eine
atheistische militär testflug mitten im
gebiet ist verteidigungsbündnisses schau
dir einfach mal diese karte an daraus
liest du die riesige konzentration von
militärischen anlagen die russland an
seiner westgrenze platziert hat in nur
20 meilen von der hessischen grenze
entfernt hat russland zum beispiel eine
luftangriffs division und einer
russischen spezialkräfte brigade
stationiert putins navy seals
viele experten gehen davon aus dass man
auch ohne die kaliningrad streitkräfte
über eine deutliche operative
überlegenheit in dieser region verfügt
die nato selbst schätzt dass die rosen
in der lage wären innerhalb weniger tage
zwischen 50 und 60 tausend mann zu
mobilisieren außerdem könnte die
bedrohung für die baltischen länder aus
verschiedenen richtungen kommen was die
verteidigung der region noch schwieriger
machen würde aber natürlich ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit eines bewaffneten
konflikts sollte relativ gering und
natürlich dürfen nicht vergessen dass
die nato als verteidigungsbündnis selbst
eine abschreckung hat selbst die russen
und fürchten sich davor eine nato
bündnisfall auszulösen aber was willst
du von dir hören fehler passieren nun
mal und wir müssen nicht nur an einen
unglücklichen zwischenfall gemäss
murphy's law denken die einflussreiche
präsenz der russischen gemeinschaft in
österreich lettland ihre geringe
integration in das zivile und politische
leben der länder und der relativ
schwache wirtschaftliche lage könnten
schocks rebellionen separatismus oder
protestbewegung begünstigen die der
stabilität der drei baltischen länder
erheblichen schaden zufügen könnten das
ist die wahre bedrohung und in diesen
spieler übrigen kriegsführung ständigen
spannungen ist russland klar im vorteil
aber was meinst du denkst du dass die
nato ihre stationierung an ihre aus
ganzer verstärken muss wie sollten die
westlichen länder deiner meinung nach
mit einer massiven hybriden
kriegsführung im baltikum umgehend wie
sie bereits in der ukraine stattgefunden
hat wie können all diese risiken
eingedämmt werden der immer sind wir auf
all eure meinung zu diesem thema
hochgradig gespannt ich hoffe also dass
durch diese videos halbes jahr geht es
mit einem leisen und pfronten und
vergesst nicht das abo mit glöckchen wo
keines unserer videos zu verpassen machs
gut und bis bald
[Musik]